uh-oh we're live we're live we're live
we're live laughs laughs love don't let
my giant hands here guys I'm just going
to promote that we are live right now
okay hello I don't know how I see who is
in here this is exciting I think I can't
tell yeah sure Hey hi hi hi hi hi hi hi
um okay I'm just gonna share this guy's
okay I want everyone to know oh yes
post there we go hey hello everyone
my voice I'm physically here but my
voice is gone ah yay people are filing
in I'll give it a moment to let everyone
file in I'll hydrate that seems like an
appropriate thing to do
happy Friday
it's Friday it's Friday happy Friday
everyone whoo this is so exciting um I'm
here sorry I'm not
I got a balance talking to you guys and
reading these comments also this is a
very curious angle you're like balance
on my laptop which is fun hi guys I'm
here at VidCon which is very very
exciting I lost my voice which is a true
sign that I'm actually at VidCon this is
not green screen I'm here right now um I
don't
I didn't pace myself and so my voice is
gone Oh Thank You Cameron for saying my
hair looks nice god bless its um I'm
doing golf fraggle today I think that's
the look I'm going for we'll see how
that works out for us uh yay wait okay
my ass looks so massive why do they look
so giant giant hands um so I wanted to
do a livestream yes this is true sexy
Friday it's a very sexy voice I went in
to livestream today from VidCon because
I did not make a video for you guys and
I felt slightly poor about that so I
hey let's hang out for a little bit I
have a few couple hours before my next
panel which should be fun
did I shower yet yeah I showered this
morning I really took care of myself I
think when you wake up with no voice the
only thing you have left to do is like
try it to take care of yourself any
other way possible so yeah I did that
yeah it's day two of VidCon it is going
very very well everyone is so nice the
weather's beautiful it's very fun I feel
old which is always a fun feeling to
have and it's great everyone's in great
mood VidCon is so exciting because
everyone's so happy to be here my makeup
I am wearing makeup yeah I am I've
covered lots of my face with makeup how
was my dog goose is not here goose is at
boarding she can't be here because she
will quite frankly murder everyone and
then I won't be able to keep her as a
dog so I put her in a safe protective
place while I'm here um so let me give
you guys a little what one this is I'm
in my hotel room like I said getting
ready to go to a panel in a little bit
at VidCon drink every time I say VidCon
and don't
I mean it's Friday TGIF you live your
life um let's recap what's happened at
VidCon so far for you guys if you're not
here you can be with me in spirit
through this vicarious recap so
yesterday
day one and what happened yesterday oh
god i won i signed a bunch of my books
grace and style and graces guide that
are at um a booth kept my brain guys I'm
very sorry my brain is so bad today that
are available at VidCon for you guys if
you want all signed books go check them
out why I decided to a livestream on
when I have no voice this is the
opposite of anything I should be doing
so all the books are signed if you guys
are having a gun or know anyone that's
at VidCon go tell them to go get them
for you then I went to the fullscreen
booth yesterday and I shot hot dogs out
of a hot dog cannon which was truly a
dream come true
fullscreen wanted me to go to their
booth at some point during the
convention and like promote not too deep
and promote their platform and they
wanted me to do something on stage and I
don't sing I don't dance but I I do dumb
and I asked so they would get a hot dog
cannon for me and they did and so a lot
of you that were there got uh kind of
shitty hot dogs and some t-shirts so if
any of you got any of those I hope you
enjoyed them um then uh what happened
after that oh boy oh boy
Oh Hannah mamrie and I had a panel which
was really really fun we have a Holy
Trinity panel every year at VidCon and
this year was no exception
we had a panel and it was great and oh
sorry I did not a Hannah's texting me
right now how appropriate uh way to
panel we talked about our pets a lot
mamrie talked about her dating life it
was very very fun I think it I don't
know of everything's live streamed your
epic on so maybe it is I don't know um
we did that and then we went to some
parties last night as you can tell I am
a garbage party monster trash human
today so I will if I meet any of you
today I will be very open
overcompensating Leah wearing perfume
and smells that's not nice so yeah uh
yeah that happened yesterday that was
yesterday oh I ate a strict diet of
chips yesterday which is always really
fun when at the end of the day you
realize that the only food group you've
had are lime flavored tortilla chips you
know I'm living that healthy la
lifestyle you guys sorry to rub it in
your face so hard okay
I'm trying to look at some comment I've
here let's just have a conversation if
you guys have any questions you guys
many things let me know I would try to
assume I can gauge the comments as as
best I can
Germany really wants to feel you in it
okay well I did have a layover in
Frankfurt when I oh that's the other
thing to it I have to remember I have to
cut myself some slack because yesterday
the day before yesterday I got to VidCon
but that morning I was in France so my
body's been through a lot in the last
like 48 hours um and so you know push it
to the limit till you regret it my mom
always said maybe uh not too deep with
VidCon stories oh okay that's a great
idea last year at VidCon we did a live
not too deep with Louise Pendergast cuz
I please here Lily let's rig a little
bitter and it was one of my favorite
episodes just to plug that if you guys
have any interest in listening to that
it's on soundcloud and itunes she is
such a hilarious story teller and so she
did a live version of not too deep with
me at VidCon last year and is really fun
so go check that out uh what is my
favorite color my favorite color is navy
blue how goddamn boring is that like
this this is visit navy blue I like it
and stripes I've ever covered stripes
I'm wearing my favorite colors right now
hamsters they exist until they don't
burn Oh bread for survival uh did I
smash no past are you sick uh in the
head probably am i physically ill um
probably but mostly I just I lose my
voice almost every single convention
because hannah has the same issue I talk
at the top of my register like I don't
talk with a belly voice if that makes
any sense to anyone so any time I met in
a loud party scenario and I'm trying to
talk to people I usually am screaming
and so it strains my voice which is
perfect for me to do a live stream in
which I am continuing to talk to you
guys yeah uh why do I feel old because I
am
is this convention there are so many
musically kids here or what I assume are
musically kids
it's just tweens and teens gathering in
groups giggling awkwardly not knowing
what to do with their bodies hugging and
I assume they're musically I have no
idea this is how but I can't judge them
because this is like how the rest of the
world saw YouTube years and years ago
it's just a gaggle of giggling teenagers
so good for them they're doing stuff I
don't know how was France France was
delightful I did push my limits on how
much cheese I could eat why I don't know
why I test my body so much
I know that I can't eat cheese but I did
so hey there's that uh do I plan on
coming to Latvia well there's no exact
plan in place at this current moment
however why not maybe in the future
Never Say Never no filter show soon
question mark I would love that we may
Marie and I talked about wanting to do
more live shows uh soon and so don't
worry we're trying to get some going
we'll let you know as soon as we figure
out where and when we are doing them
where would you guys like no filter
shows we've done them so far in the US
Australia Dublin and the will the UK
Dublin and London but we want to go
other places so let us know where we
should do that uh Colorado
I heart food oh yeah did you guys hear
Hannah Hart if you don't know the lowly
Hannah Hart she announced her Food
Network show the premiere date and the
title of the show it's called I heart
food I'm really excited for premiering
in August August something go to her
channel she just uploaded a video
yesterday announcing the title and the
premiere date and she just lovely so go
support that little hamster talking
about hamsters nice boys how did you
like Iceland I liked Iceland a lot
Iceland was fun beautiful and everyone
was nice and it had a very like bizarre
obsession with like American culture in
this like fun way that didn't make sense
but neither do myself or handle
memory makes sense as human being so I
think we fit in pretty well also one of
the joys in life that I didn't realize
that I needed was watching Hannah try to
UM
ride a four-wheeler a little fact about
Hannah if you don't know it she's not to
ride a bike so I riding a four-wheeler
was oh she was so overwhelmed and it was
really sweet to see I loved it okay any
collabs coming soon yeah I want I have
this idea I want to I got to work more
on my channel your guess but and it's
always very inspiring to come to VidCon
every year because you leave feeling
like very excited about what everyone's
doing I'm very driven by community
cetera so I have some ideas for series
that I want to start on the channel that
are more collaborative that will get
more people involved because I bring so
many people on to my podcast that I
assume that I've collaborated with them
already but then I realized that that's
my podcast it's not for my channel so I
want to start doing more videos with
people on my channel let me know if you
guys have any specific once needs
desires or ideas for videos and people
that I should collaborate with because I
want to how are you today grace I'm
hanging in I'm a scraggly Fraggle that's
ready for the PGA Tour undoing it I come
to Rochester New York that sounds like
maybe not my first choice on travel but
maybe are you wearing a weave big time
like 80% of this hair is fake right now
and like a hundred percent of it is like
falling out constantly so I'm fully
anticipating I'm doing a meet-and-greet
here tomorrow
I am fully anticipating that extensions
will be falling out left and right
during the meet-and-greet so please if I
meet any of you don't pull up the hair I
need it for as long as I can get it
Wendy my hair girl was out of town so I
did no time to get it fixed before
VidCon so I'm doing the best I can
huh
oh gosh these comments are going so
that's are you sick you okay yeah I'm
okay um come to Israel like Oh drag race
guys Oh anyone anyone ever hear of
RuPaul's Drag Race
tonight is the season finale I think
that Rick he's got tonight's the season
finale it's pretty it's ready uh and we
got to go
maimry and I got to go to the taping of
the season finale so we know who's in
the top two but they film at the taping
multiple endings so we actually don't
know who won we're going to find out
with everyone else the rest of the world
tonight who actually want so they film
different versions of who won so they
have it so that no one leaves and is
able to spoil so I'm excited if who were
you guys rooting for any favorites in
the game cool suck my dick
no thank you Pass big ole pecs please
you have nice teeth thank you hey you
say season three I would love hey USA
season through you guys may mean I went
to New York to try and pitch a osa
season three to a bunch of advertisers
and now we have to like kind of sit and
wait to see if anyone wants to fund it
because we can't can't do it by
ourselves so we have to get someone to
financially back the project and trust
us we are chomping at the bit to travel
with each other and to do a season three
of that show I didn't get to really
participate in season two so it would be
very fun to do a season three I'm making
a cake do you want some of course of
course you know they make cookie crisp
cereal cookies for breakfast I don't
know why I haven't made like cake crisp
a cake for breakfast kick cereal I guess
that's like cinnamon toast crap no
that's toast
I'll talk with myself offline about this
uh go to drink question mark
maybe I tried to get a bland honestly
for this live stream tried to order
myself a Bloody Mary but I'd in the
lobby bar downstairs but it's for pickup
only and I wasn't about to leave the
room it's dangerous out there in the
real world I'm nice and safe here in the
comfort of my poorly lit room so for a
natural lighting drew Monson yeah oh by
the way um have you guys heard of
fantasies it's this new show that's on
full screen where they're taking
fanfiction and basically making short
form narratives using the fanfiction
it's kind of like my drunk my drunk
history
it's kind of like drunk history and kind
of like a soap opera merged in one and
mamrie directed an episode that Hannah
and I are in it's a fanfiction that one
of you guys wrote about us and it's up
on full screen right now and drew Monson
is kind of like the narrator of the
whole series and it's really fun so go
check it out I think that just went live
yesterday and I think there's two
episodes um so go check that out
uh what are my opinions on socks that I
don't have anyone right now oh but I
have pizza socks so I'm just a parody of
an Internet girl god dang I love your
hair thank you
mostly not mine but I appreciate it
uh what would my favorite Oreo flavor be
guys in a way that I don't love Oreos ah
if they replace the crunchy cookie part
with like soft chocolate chip cookies I
think I like them a lot more that's just
like good
Ice Cream Sandwich basically um I don't
know who this woman is yeah well hi nice
to meet you
I love from Argentina hello Argentina
thank you for being your Argentina
what's my favorite restaurant noticed me
please I see you um my favorite well the
dumb quick answer is Cheesecake Factory
maybe and I like to get some skinny
licious cocktails and some you know
scaler salads just be like the most
basic versions of ourselves possible and
you're in a safe basic place to do so so
I like that hey love from New Zealand
how long is deal in New Zealand in
Argentina yeah that's awesome
well well ah would I ever go to South
Africa I would go to South Africa I
would like to go to South Africa that's
a place on my short list that I would
like to go to ah love from South Africa
right the more reason to go there's much
love their thoughts on Harry Styles yes
please gimme debt please very well
where's your shirt from oh this shirt
this is like a men's shirt from H&M no I
was re this is a dress and I cut it and
then I folded it now it's a shirt
because you can do anything you want to
do in this life uh hi from Hungary and
the Czech Republic guy yes sir really
representing a lot of the universe or
the world rather that's awesome
and Michigan sweet uh what's my favorite
color I think I answered that navy blue
and stripes meow cool perfect Wonder
Woman and Electra woman would be friends
I think they'd be very good friends I
haven't seen Wonder Woman yet you guys
see it did you like it Gail Godot I mean
we're all waiting for kal Godot
bye come to New York don't tell me what
to do but I would like that Taylor Swift
is putting her music back on Spotify I
didn't even know it wasn't on Spotify
but that's exciting does that change
your world
alright cool Minnesota represents hey
Minnesota which medieval times is the
best I don't know I can't answer that
honestly I've only been to two different
locations so of the two I've been -
they're both like mutually very great
excuse me disgusting sorry I'm by
sailing me in so many ways
Hogwarts alright
it yep got it these with Katy Perry
mm-hmm I would eat beef jerky with Katy
Perry for sure uh I was translating your
videos so much fun thank you have you
guys didn't know I tweeted this out
yesterday that I opened my videos up to
be translated into different languages
because there's a community-driven thing
where you guys can if you want if you
have any free time or any desire can
translate my videos so that people in
other countries can watch them and enjoy
them and not understand the humor in
them perfect
what Hogwarts house for you I'm a
Hufflepuff and I'm so happy about it
also happy to be off above I think
they're nice and creative and kind and
fun and so that's me anyone else I'll
have a puff out there I don't Lee Newton
is Apple pop she's the one that actually
forced me to take the test the first
time around years and years ago when we
work on my music together and she's also
have a buff and so it was a very bonding
moment for us to be puff-puffs together
Slytherin oh okay Griffin Dale Griffin
Dale alright
that's an interesting house house goose
goose is doing well I think music
question mark I've heard of that thing
before that's my favorite drink
um alcoholic Lee speaking
one my favorite I love dirty uh vodka
martinis straight up with olives
cheapest lacquer you have no III like I
like dirty martinis um and I drink vodka
sodas like water they they don't cause
as much of a hangover as most alcoholic
beverages tend to do there's that a lot
less sugar in that drink so that's my
go-to my favorite non-alcoholic drink is
coffee for sure
I love coffee I look forward to it every
morning and also various other points
throughout the day every day orange is
the new black I haven't seen the most
recent season
no spoilers is a good cup is a good
though okay
do you like Riverdale I also haven't
seen that guys I haven't what look
here's the deal I watch Real Housewives
I watch every reality program that is a
veil
on Bravo TV right now and that is the
extent to which I'm watching TV at the
moment oh and I started the most recent
season of The Amazing Race don't spoil
anything for me it's not Tyler and Korey
season it's the last one the end where
it's like a bunch of singles that get
paired up with people as potential mates
and they do the race together I'm only
doing the first episode so I'm excited
to watch this season hello from Germany
how about Germany thoughts on Charles oh
my god you guys
Hannah's got a new cat named Charles if
you didn't know now you know and this
cat the photos and the videos you guys
don't do it justice this little thing
this little little felt covered tire of
a teeny cat is the most amazing thing
I've ever experienced I didn't know I
needed him in my life until he's been in
my life he's incredible I'm very proud
of Hannah for getting a pet that suits
her so perfectly and I just want to hang
out with that little alien thing all the
time
mamrie and I keep comparing him to
things because we can't fully process
I've never seen or experienced a cat
like him before so for us to understand
him we just keep using these metaphors
to describe what he looks like us and he
looks like at the end of the movie big
when Tom Hanks gets back to being a
little kid and he walks back into his
house and he's wearing this man suit
newsroom before it's like flops all
around that's Charles's skin looks like
it looks like he was a bigger cat that
went back to being a kitten but he's
still wearing the bigger cat suit and
it's just kind of loose and floppy on
his skin so he is adorable I'm proud of
him for existing am i coming to VidCon
Australia at this point I don't think so
but I'm trying to make work we'll see
how it goes um I know a lot of other
people are and I really want to go but I
might be working on something so I'll
let you guys know if I find out upcoming
books third book mm-hmm trying um if you
guys were to read a third book from me
and tweet at me too because these
comments are going so fast if you were
to read a third book for me what type of
book might you want so we have Grace's
guide which is just kind of an
marking self-help book parity and then
we've Grayson style which is a style
guide parody what kind of third book
would you be curious about for me I am
thinking in this this is just like you
know fresh brainstorm like love
relationship parody guide does that have
any interest any of you just thrown that
out there let me know marinate on it and
let's see if we can cook a steak later
grace crafts okay life stories it's hard
to write life stories because I feel
like I've told you guys over the course
of the last like 10 years of making
videos on the internet every possible
semi interesting thing about myself Oh a
parenting book oh that's a good idea
interesting um no I feel like I've told
you guys every quasi interesting piece
of anything in my entire life so there's
not much left to tell and not enough
that would fit into a book form so we'll
see oh man I look like a maniac that's
fun
looked like I just finished 18 holes and
someone blew a leaf blower straight into
my face perfect that's my aesthetic
um collab with Liza I want to she's
absolutely fantastic I think she's
absolutely wonderful and I want to make
a video with her give me ideas for
videos guys send up some suggestions
would I ever come to Germany yes I would
that's on my short list because I've
never been to Germany I've been a lot of
places in Europe and I just had a
layover in a ginger in Frankfurt but Kim
never spent proper time there and I
would like to Jason said I look great
god bless you Jason you look like an all
fits executive thank you for that
compliment acting career
I'm trying some stuff we'll see
hopefully things move forward and I can
tell you guys about some projects in the
future that might be exciting but you
know as the classic we'll see scenario
hi from Brazil hi Brazil pineapple okay
great
whatever come to the Netherlands yeah of
course of course
grace you HOT though I am my body
temperature
trying to sweat I think it's because my
body is reaching the haze where the
hangover sets in and it is drastically
trying to remove the toxins in any way
so that's fun I get to go be like this
on a panel in a little bit yeah what set
represents me hmm hmm what scent
represents me ah let's see
like um hmm what scent represents me
like a like a like a pleasant Musk that
might be the name Oh
oh yeah that might be the name of a
perfume if I released one
well-intentioned Musk you must have it
by Switzerland all right come to
Slovakia sure guys commenting on daily
graces videos I'm good uh grace I just
ate so much what something okay I hope
you're okay I excited for any movies
coming out this year guys I do not keep
up with movies I am bad at keeping up
with movies you tell me what I should be
excited about and I'll do it for you
guys just let me know I do want to see
Wonder Woman though that is something I
do want to see I don't know what else is
coming out this year but hopefully cool
things oh the emoji movie that's right I
have seen a lots of billboards for the
emoji movie I don't know what to feel
about it I like that they had to get new
they had to like slightly alter the
emojis because I don't think they had
the rights to use the actual know Jesus
and that makes me laugh - Poland hello
Poland merch question mark um yeah
there's going to be some stuff some but
excuse me my body is just trying to
dispel toxins I apologize uh birch
there's going to be some curious
interesting new merch that I've never
sort of dabbled in before coming out
soon so get ready if you like
accessories this might be cool for you
uh what's my favorite Netflix show
what's up your Netflix show haters back
off guys guys were Colleen I'm about to
go be on a panel with her talking about
the crossover from Internet to like
traditional media so I'm gonna hear all
about I'm so excited that girl works her
ass off I love her very much and she's
super super talented so I'm super happy
for everything that she's got going on
my favorite Hulu show I don't know it
saves my call who do I like sausage you
know I like I go Wayne
uh can I invite you to my wedding of
course you can send me an invite I
probably can't go but I appreciate the
offer and happy marriage to you and your
significant other is crazy face still a
thing I mean that just happens so maybe
when will you go back to short hair soon
these extensions are really hurting the
sanctity of my natural hair so I think I
will take them out and go back to shore
air for the rest of the summer and let
it be okay let it fix itself prom
question Burke I've heard of a prom good
luck to you and your prom I hope you're
fun uh I like cheese me too thoughts on
lamps they're illuminating where's the
watch from oh this nope not that there
we go there it is this is a Calvin Klein
watch that I got from UM Calvin Klein
the suite at VidCon Amsterdam they're
also here they gave me pcs thoughts oh
no oh God you guys okay
oh my god I'm so sorry I didn't mean to
do that this box is from them when I got
here and they gave me a bunch of like
free clothes they're very very generous
and also very much my aesthetic I like
them very much so thank you but this I
don't use this for time I just use it as
a bracelet I don't even know what time
is this set - I know this says it is 935
I took me a long time to figure out what
a minute
uh can I be the Beast to your beauty
we're just two beasts let's just be two
beasts in a pod I'm trying to go see
Coldplay all right good luck with that
bro
have fun tell Chris Martin was up high
from New Jersey hi new truth you tell my
mama said hi that I'm okay someone s
about laura dern yeah I was just in can
France
like I said for Ken Lyons this
advertising festival and I got to speak
I got to do this like moderated talk
with Laura Dern which is like insane
that I got to do that and also you know
if you're meeting a celebrity you wonder
how they're gonna be and she couldn't be
kinder she was so sweet so nice and just
so genuinely curious about the Internet
and just really present which is very
rare that people when they speak to you
feel like they're actually listening and
engaging with you so I really
appreciated that a lot she's great
Hey and also I started watching the
first episode a big little eyes but I
was distracted so I have to like sit and
start watching have you guys seen it
everyone talks wonderfully about it so I
have to check it oh oh oh God
I'm not bred for survival especially not
today ah
have I watched Downton Abbey I watched a
couple episodes on a plane and it was
completely out of context but it seemed
it seemed interesting pitch perfect
family the cast to pitch perfect 3 is
here at big gun and I have an
opportunity to take a photo with them
tomorrow and Kendrick you guys know
Hannah Kenter is like my girl cut crash
extreme supreme and I think she's here
at VidCon I'd like I don't I can't I had
a lot happen in last 48 hours how am I
supposed to process that I'm supposed
though there's an opportunity to go take
a photo with them tomorrow but I think
I'm doing a meet-and-greet so I don't
know god I can't I can't even handle it
Golf dad can't handle it um I I also
have to go I wanted to do this for a
half hour with you guys just to say like
thanks for participating in my channel
and I'm sorry I don't have a new video
for you today I'm also thinking about
switching things up a little bit maybe
possibly I don't know just found out
that tell me what you think doing live
streams every
instead of a video what would that be
like for you guys let me know
we'll talk online and offline about it
I'm gonna go get ready to go be on a
panel with wonderful human beings I hope
you guys are having a really great
Friday if you're at VidCon um say hi if
you see me and if you're not have a gun
um well you know good luck with your
lives have a great weekend guys I will
see you on the internet as always I
don't know